my name is Chris Ma and I'm the
executive director of the Acton
Institute which is an educational and
public policy thinktank concerned with
the intersection of religion and free
market economics our namesake in case
you're interested is Lord Acton who was
the fellow who said power tends to
corrupt and absolute power corrupts
absolutely and I'm willing to wager that
most of the world's problems that we can
Envision are at least partly caused by
the hubris of power corrupted political
Elites so if you want to take me up on
that challenge please please
do uh I'm lucky to be here on a regular
basis annually for this terrific
conference um I'm not sure it's because
of my good looks or erudition um I think
it's because I'm an Advisory Board
member uh which I'm I'm humbled to be
and that means I get to throw lots of
ideas at Anita in a couple phone calls s
and she has the great task of sifting
through and tossing out the dumb ones
and putting together this terrific
program so thank you Anita for all the
very hard work that you
do and of course thank you to Hillsdale
what a great institution to bring all of
us together and to the derell foundation
for so generously supporting this annual
conversation now our panel topic
is economic lessons from the economic
Union and I'm going to warn you in
advance it's not a pretty picture in
Europe Europe is in trouble on all
fronts politically economically
culturally and some would argue even
their very security threatened
militarily I know these themes will
arise throughout the panel and I I for
one don't like being pessimistic about
Europe many of us in this room come from
Europe at one
point I love many things about Europe I
love visiting I love the food languages
art all kinds of things I don't like
their politics and economics and if
we're headed in that direction please
save us which I think is the panel's job
today is to warn us what not to do so uh
without further Ado I'm going to turn it
over to our first Speaker Christopher
Caldwell he's a senior editor The Weekly
Standard uh an author of a terrific book
called Reflections on the revolution in
Europe from a couple years ago I suspect
he's invited because that book uh
created a bit of a conversation at that
time uh around challenges to European
culture over Islamic
immigration uh we ain't seen nothing yet
I imagine that's the theme of your your
talk uh he writes about American and
European Affairs for many European and
American Publications and I'm told he's
on uh working on a new book about
America in the wake of the 1960s please
join me in welcoming Christopher
Caldwell uh thank you very much um and
I'd like to thank um Hillsdale for for
having me uh for inviting me and
especially Anita fulam for having um uh
arranged to make this this all possible
um I'm not going to be able to give a
very uh wide ranging um talk today one
of the beautiful things about
immigration as a subject is the way it
draws in almost every aspect of you know
human social life you know from
economics to culture to languages to
everything but um this is an economic
Forum I'd like to focus on a couple of
um on a couple of economic aspects of
immigration and specifically uh on ways
in which let's say the mid 20th century
welfare state has uh distorted some of
the incentives around um immigration
they're a little different in Europe
these distortions than they are in the
United States but I think that we can
learn from them nonetheless just to to
give a little bit of current events
background I think uh maybe some of you
have been watching what's been going on
in in in Central Europe now you have um
uh refugees from the war in Syria have
begun to you know lose patience with
staying in camps in in Jordan and and
Lebanon and um and turkey uh and have
begun to move towards Europe and and
over the
summer uh Angela Merle the uh chairman
of Germany uh said that Germany could
probably welcome about 800,000 of them
uh uh and uh thus far they have um 1.5
million that's the projection in Germany
alone uh and there's a there's a there's
a problem with this uh with this
particular migration which
is uh that that while the route may have
opened due to the war in Syria it's a it
is a real business the the the the the
business of moving migrants is a
business it's a very lucrative and it's
a it's quite a service you can provide
to a family if you can get them out of
poverty and into a European uh welfare
state so no one should ever call these
uh traffickers of of of of migrants um
exploiters because if at least they're
not exploiters in the sense that they're
that they're offering um the the people
that their clients a worthless uh uh
commodity but anyway this route can be
traveled not just by syrians but also by
um by Iraqis Irani I um pakistanis
afghanis bangladeshis and I I met all of
them on a on a recent um uh trip to to
to Austria a couple weeks ago so what so
what you have is an
an a declaration which which has wound
up being a declaration of open borders
to Syria which has been taken up by
people from all over the Middle East and
that's what Europe is undergoing now and
it is I have to say if you will pardon
my idiomatic language it is really
freaking European publics out and um uh
it is turning politics upside down and
and and and I think that one of
the reasons that it has been hard to
offer a a resistance to this in in in
European parliaments is that there's a
great deal of Mythology built up about
how uh uh Mass immigration is always
good for a country I mean you run down
the list you know when you say well I'm
really worried about the
immigration um Europeans will respond
okay well what's wrong with it I mean
what's wrong with helping these people
who've been fleeing this war that you
see on TV I mean it's it's horrible you
look at the people dying over there and
and you'd really have no answer to that
except you say but they're not all
fleeing the war and the next question is
well don't immigrants build up an
economy and that's you know and and the
answer is yes they can under certain
circumstances but um I think that the
European economy has been distorted in
such a way that it benefits less from
immigration than ours does so that's
what I'll talk about there's a when
Europeans defend their uh defend Mass
immigration they tend to do do so in in
two ways when they defend the idea that
there's a per persistent structural need
for it they there's a they make a some
sometimes they make a a capitalist case
um and sometimes they make a which is
that it Strang the economy and sometimes
they make a socialist state which is
that it strengthens the state and um I
think both arguments are are somewhat
illogical all right the capitalist case
is this um Mass immigration is good
because immigrants take jobs that no
European will do now what's really meant
by this is that that immigr immigrants
take jobs that no European will do at
a dear at a particular wage
um and and these jobs tend to be ones
that have fallen out of the European
social welfare state system stuff that
you know Europeans have a very generous
welfare state but there are still jobs
that are not
worth um you know adding full health
care and uh 20 or 30 years of retirement
benefits to a certain um menial jobs
foreigners main qualification from these
for these jobs is their low expectations
now about a decade ago the immigra uh
the immigration specialist uh uh Philip
Martin of the University of California
Davis and some of his colleagues they
drew parallels that I thought were very
fruitful between today's migrations and
the movement of wouldbe settlers to
European colonies in the 18th
century back then migrants often paid
the cost of their resettlement through
an indenture that is they' Promised a
promise a given number of years of Labor
to the landowner who fronted their their
voyage and I think that maybe today
immigrants are are paying a kind of a an
updated form of indenture they pay it in
the form of Rights they live in an
ambiguous legal status that condemns
them to only the lowest
jobs
um and so if there really are jobs that
Europeans won't do this indenture that
that that immigrants labor under is a
big part of what natives believe they're
getting out of immigration now whether
or not this indenture is fair depends
totally on the Contex context in which
you view it on one hand it's really
corrosive it creates uh two years of it
creates two tiers of Rights in a in a
destination country you know and and we
had to talk about this a little bit with
um uh Obama's projected IM immigration
reforms which are not which are not holy
without without arguments you know you
have people living in the country for 20
years uh they've been working the whole
time um and yet they cannot um they
cannot change change jobs on the other
hand um the immigration immigrants in
their own native context in the context
of the countries where they came from
they are unlikely to complain they're
doing much better than they would have
done in their native
countries and so there's a big argument
to be had on both sides but even if you
like this Arrangement there is a hitch
to it because the benefits of this
indenture acre to the immigrants new
countries only so long as immigrants are
illegal and transitional people always
talk about stopping illegal immigration
but I'm afraid that for the purposes
purely of economics if we could
ignore the political corrosion of law
breaking and just stress on dollars and
cents for in for the purpose of
Economics illegal immigrants are
preferable to Legal ones okay and and
and and the problem as far as the
economy is concerned is that um or as as
far as the people who hire these people
are concerned is that immigrants don't
stay that way forever as soon as they're
legally and socially assimilated in a
way in the way that Society professes to
want they acquire a lot of Rights and
expectations in the European context
they become Europeans and they become
these and once they become Europeans
they become people who by definition
won't do the jobs that Europeans won't
do um you know what I mean so so you're
you're struck with a real you're stuck
with a real Paradox here which is the
moment immigration is successful
socially the main economic reason that
Society thinks it needs immigrants
evaporates and and and and that has
consequences
for what you're getting when you get
Mass immigration Mass immigration
snowballs it's a kind of a a treadmill
because as soon as as to use two
metaphors that don't really go together
as soon as Europeans as soon as these
immigrants become Europe Europeans then
in order to ensure that these jobs no
European wants get done Society has to
recruit a new replacement Army of
foreign born workers without rights and
this sounds like sounds a great deal
like the way Carl Marx describes um
capitalism there is an alternative and
the alternative is to maintain the
precariousness of immigrants legal
status into the Next Generation
by denying Birthright citizenship but
that doesn't sound like a very
satisfactory arrangement for a republic
either either way you get in a situation
where the gains the economic gains from
immigration are paid back in later
generations the economic gains from
immigration are borrowed they're not
earned so they you acre economic costs
either you acrew economic costs or you
you pay off these economic costs in the
form of constitutional rights this is a
rather complex point that I go into a
lot more in my book and I don't really
have time to really get into here my my
my main point about this capitalist case
is that it the capitalist case for
immigration is that it doesn't reckon
with the the damage that is done by the
way that societies get addicted to
immigration now let's talk about the
socialist case which quite naturally you
hear a lot more of
um uh in Europe we have a picture in our
head of the European welfare state in
its Heyday which is which is right now
it's probably a little bit exaggerated
there there are countries like Austria
and maybe France that retain that kind
of old-fashioned welfare state of you
know like the 32-hour week and the seven
week vacation and you know and and uh
you know uh uh pensions that are like
right next to your maximum earnings and
um you know total free healthare but
other European welfare states like
Germany um Britain have have really they
they they've they've cut back Europeans
used to always condescend to Americans
about our the difference between our
welfare state and theirs you know they'd
say things like well Americans live to
work but we Europeans we work to live
you you know and and so you know aren't
we Grand you know and so you look you we
can now see and I don't want to be too
rude about it but you know in the wake
of the 2008 crash it seems more likely
that any differences in the system can
be accounted for by Europeans having
taken more from the future having you
know borrowed more on the future than
Americans did which by the way is no
mean feet um now in in in Europe
as in as here this system wound up
spurring immigration in unanticipated
ways okay and that's because all
government pension
systems operate whatever they may call
use the word trust fund but that's
balone they all operate on a pay as youo
basis that is they pay present benefits
to retirees out of present tax receipts
they don't let no individual worker
saves for his retirement through Social
Security okay pists and Welfare
economists um have always noted the
tendency of such systems as they come
under Democratic pressure to degenerate
into Ponzi schemes that is they they
they they they lead politicians to
overpromise and to cover those promises
by roping in new investors that is
taxpayers to transferer more money to
current beneficiaries than the system
can really afford in exchange for votes
you know and in societies with growing
populations this can really work because
I mean for a short time because the
welfare support ratio grows too the
welfare support ratio is the ratio of
laborers to beneficiaries you know um
but politicians are tempted to loot for
their own purposes the entire Surplus
that com comes from having a temporary
bulge of people in of working age rather
than invest it for the time when that
bulge of workers becomes a bulge of
retirees you know um Europe's
politicians were not any more capable of
resisting this temptation than our
politicians were and so after the baby
boom entered uh the baby boom generation
went to work these ratios grew and grew
and grew and now that the Boomers are
retiring the support ratio is shrinking
fast I mean in in in countries like
Spain I would like to look at the actual
ratio now but it's it's heading towards
2: one which is you know uh which is a
very low ratio now and due to Falling
birth rates which is a problem that
feeds into this um and is tied to it in
complex ways there is no Next Generation
of workers large enough to restore the
system to balance so uh a reckoning
awaits or it used to await now it's here
okay and now so who is going to save
this system who is going to be the
generator of jobs and productivity that
is going to pay for Europeans
retirements um a lot of Europeans say
immigrants they will pay for it we'll
bring people in it'll be great and and
and and and and and so they're the sort
of
the the way I put it a few years ago is
that these people are supposed to sort
of emerge from the desiccated and
starving hamlets of the third world and
ride to the rescue of the retirement
checks and second homes the wine takes
tastings and snorkeling vacations of the
most pampered Workforce in the history
of the planet I think I so I I think I
wrote that at about 3:00 in the
morning but but but uh uh it that's not
going to work either and um I I there
there there there are a few reasons
which I'll zip through before I end
first is the welfare state requires a
lot more newcomers to prop it up than
any public will tolerate I mean Europe
is very upset now about what looks like
it's going to be one or two million
people this year it's going to grow a
lot next year but the United Nations
population division calcul does
calculations of how many immigrants
Europe would need to to pay for its
welfare state um it's interesting that
the the the the United Nation thinks
this is a a proper thing to do as if the
welfare state is like a fact of nature
that needs to be preserved in Europe you
know but it would take uh about 154
million immigrants in mid-century to no
I mean so we're talking about a third of
the country's population the country
would have to grow by a third and it
would have to all be working age um
young people and they and that that
would save it except that it wouldn't
and the reason it wouldn't is that
immigrants are not Immortal they too age
and retire and the system has to take
care of them and they're larger than
average families and Europeans have
tended to face this problem with little
more than wishful thinking I want to
quote something from a UK home office
report from late 2007 it wrote in the
long term migrants themselves will age
and contribute to the increasing
dependency ratio but only assuming that
they remain in the UK during their
retirement so so this this is the
Assumption this is the Assumption of of
Britain's government okay the assumption
is these people are going to come at the
start of their career they're going to
slave for British retirement benefits
for 45 years and then just on the eve of
the moment when they can actually
collect them they're going to go back
home and they're going to like live in
the Sahara somewhere you know um and say
no you can keep the money I did it
because I love the British welfare state
so much um uh so and and and there's a
the third reason is immigrants don't
earn enough um and and maybe that will
change but it will be a matter of it
will be a matter of of generations you
know before that happens it's not and
and and and and I have to say that the
final reason uh and the main reason um
that that that this is that that that
immigra migrants do not provide a rescue
for the European social system is
that immigration on the scale envisioned
will transform Europe and transform
European identities and transform the
peoples and the institutions to the
point where a term such as welfare state
while people may still employ it will
have a totally different meaning because
it will be in a totally different
cultural context a Europe with hundreds
of millions of non-europeans in it is
going to want non-european things um uh
I'm not saying that non-europeans can't
become Europeans there are many examples
of that that you can read about every
day but for them to become Europeans
requires a certain amount of social
pressure on migrants and when that when
migrants come in the tens of millions to
a uh uh a continent that is short of
workers short of aan and short of
self-con confidence they're unlikely to
feel that pressure so thank you very
much thank you Christopher uh just
coincidentally about six weeks ago I was
in turkey and then Hungary just at the
moment of the worst in hungry with
people sleeping by the thousands in
front of the trains and walking
literally uh
toward uh the rest of Europe through
through Hungary and the day that they
closed the fence and I have to tell you
it's impossible to underestimate the
level of angst and conversation across
all of Europe on this particular issue
so so thank you Christopher for raising
that to our attention now our next
panelist is going to talk about another
significant uh major European crisis
with lots of uh Ripple effects over time
that is seems to be so much of
yesterday's problem the problem of
Greece but we know as I know John will
probably surely tell us this will be a
problem for tomorrow and probably Beyond
many tomorrows because it's a it's a
problem that keeps getting kicked down
the
road so helping us to understand the
particular issue of Greece and what that
portends for the rest of Europe I'd like
to invite John O Sullivan here now many
of you know John he's a journalist
author and lecturer and a current fellow
of the National Review Institute he's
also an editor at large uh for National
Review and he was in fact the editor and
chief for almost a decade until
1998 um he also as many of you will know
was a special adviser with a very
special long-standing intellectual and
personal friendship with prime minister
Margaret Thatcher one of our movement's
great Heroes uh and he's the author of a
fantastic book called the president the
pope and the Prime Minister on the roles
of Thatcher President Reagan and Pope
John Paul II in the collapse of
Communism and the Revival of Western uh
democracies um Mr Sullivan is also the
former executive editor of radio radio
free Europe and radio Liberty now to
help Enlighten us on Greece past present
and future John O
Sullivan
okay thank you well first of all Mr
chairman many thanks for your kind words
which I very much appreciate uh secondly
um it's a great pleasure to be on the
platform with Christopher Caldwell and
Barbara Co both of whom I know in fact
uh one of the two things I do at the
moment edit quadrant in Australia and
run a small think tank in Budapest
called The danub Institute it's quite a
commute
uh one of the uh things we've done at
the Danel Institute is to have a
conference jointly with Barbara and her
Institute and and in fact it was the
free market Road Show and it had similar
intentions to this today Christopher is
an old friend whom I've managed to
persuade occasionally to write for the
various magazines I work for um I you
may have noticed if you weren't paying
close attention to Christopher you
should have been paying that for a few
minutes there I was uh I had a I was
feeling a complete and utter desperation
because um my speech couldn't be G
gouged out of the internet system and um
I hadn't yet got the laptop uh I hope I
carried it off gallantly but I certainly
felt a bit nervous um but that said let
me say that I want to begin with a
straightforward thank you it's a priv
pril to be invited to this forum which
like all events run by Hillsdale is a
fine blend of high living and high
thinking to the extent that the motto of
the organization might well be men's SAA
incorpor Sano we all benefit from both
aspects and we meet old friends on both
side of the podium so many thanks um on
this occasion uh we do have a very rich
topic here and the college has given
this panel a particularly Rich subject
the European Union its current Refugee
and migrant crisis this long running
crisis built around the Euro and finally
how the Euro and its different crisis
have impacted on Greece I should say
that there's no way in which I'm not
going to intrude somewhat on Barbara's
topic it's just unavoidable really uh
but but um I I don't think we'll be
saying very different things except we
probably will be saying them very
differently
uh now um all of these uh questions are
interrelated each one affects the other
and all are potentially very damaging
now now that's obviously true of the
refugee crisis just described by
Christopher it's also obvious I think
about the long running Greece crisis
which has provoked three elections this
year alone I mean two elections and a
referendum destroyed two major governing
parties in the country and installed in
power a semi- trotskyist leader with
tires to Venezuela Castro and the
world's far left as for the third third
topic you may once have thought that
currently fluctuations and exchange rate
were rather d subjects Oscar wild knew
better in The Importance of Being
Earnest he has Miss prism tell her pupil
CES you will read your political economy
in my absence the chapter on the fall of
the rupe you may omit it is somewhat too
Sensational even these metallic problems
have their melodramatic side well they
do indeed and in the past three years
European politics has been royed by the
constant problems that have emerged over
the relationship between Greece and the
Euro these are included a series of of
funding crisis for countries inside the
Euro that found themselves at risk of
being unable to borrow on the
international markets because investors
doubted they could meet their interest
payments a series second a series of
financial baylights of these countries
by the EU and the IMF that were both
that were both against the rules of the
institutions um and then of course in
addition various short-term fixes that
led mainly to the next Crisis and the
next bailout a protracted recession
third a protracted recession in southern
Europe leading to youth unemployment
levels of over 50% and the unemployment
levels of um of of um
adults um sometimes above 20% generally
between 10 and 20 the rise number four
the rise of extremist parties across
Europe um and uh especially in Greece in
Spain and in Italy and finally five the
removal of two democratically El leaders
leaders in Greece and Italy as a result
of a shady conspiracy between Brussels
Berlin and in one case the Italian
presidency um if you read Tim G's
Memoirs there's a there's an interesting
reference to this something he's uneasy
and Sh shameful about unless you know
what it is you couldn't possibly work it
out from what he says but when you know
that the administration was engaged in a
conspiracy to get rid of berkone it
becomes you can follow it in then now
all these three crisis show something in
common they arose because the EU had
embarked upon major Collective political
reforms without thinking seriously about
possible consequences and unexpected
consequences and possible solutions if
they should fail for instance the shenen
reforms abolished internal Frontier
controls throughout Europe without
ensuring first that Europe's external
borders excuse me um were were secure so
once a migrant entered one European
country he could move freely through all
European countries getting off a boat at
Bari in the morning he could be in
Berlin by dinnertime and that's how a
refugee crisis
Begins the problem of Greece is a subset
of the Euro problem which arises from
the fact that the euro is a political
project far more than it is an economic
one it was put in place a decade ago uh
with purely uh with with features that a
purely economic project would never have
Incorporated it included too many
countries their economic characters were
too Divergent their levels of employment
inflation and productivity were too
different their financial structures for
housing and pensions were in conflict
and so on and so on the overall result
of these differences um in was that some
countries notably those in the
Mediterranean around the Mediterranean
were locked by the euro into to an
overvalued exchange rate in comparison
with elsewhere notably those countries
bordering the Baltic including Germany
it was impossible to set a single
interest rate that would be suitable for
all of them an interest rate that held
back economic growth in one country
would encourage Reckless borrowing in
another by incidentally both the public
and the private sectors also unlike the
dollar the pound the public and um
dollar the pound um the REM nimi the
Swiss frank the Euro did not have a
proper system of government there was no
economic government of the Euro Zone um
it that could run a europe-wide fiscal
policy in line with the European Central
bank's monetary policy and though these
features of the Euro guaranteed economic
dislocation and perverse outcomes the
Euro did not Zone did not have three
things needed to reconcile those
differences or deal with the
dislocations it didn't have flexibility
of wages it didn't have transnational
labor mobility in practice uh and it
didn't have transnational monetary
transfers in fact the Euro was sold to
the Germans by saying by the slogan no
bailouts um which was soon
forgotten uh well we could say more
about those things U but it became the
Euro became very quickly a fetish for
Germany's political Elites and over time
a fetish for all of Europe's political
Elites and as you may recall from
Herbert Spencer
he said that anyone who denied the
government fetish suffered a terrible
fate he was described as a believer in
ler and no one ever heard of him again
uh equally uh anyone who denied the Euro
fetish uh was banished from mass media
to the obscurity of small opinion
magazines today it is hardly possible to
deny that the deniers had a point but
the fetish continues to exert some power
now I better skip ahead there then you
I'm limited to 20 minutes Mr President
but once I start talking I lose all
sense of time so you're going to have to
tell me when I have three minutes to
go uh let me offer a few criticisms of
of why that's a bad thing which leads
directly to Greece the first and most
important is that it is the most um the
policies well skip ahead there
too
um we've concent ated a lot in the Euro
on the funding crisis but in fact even
when that is completely solved which I
don't think it has been uh the the
Mediterranean countries still remain
locked into a vertiginously unfavorable
exchange rate represented by the Euro
and in so far as they remain in the
currency they will be locked into that
exchange rate and in economic austerity
Without End at the same time Northern
Europe will be locked into paying an
endless flow of subsidies to them this
represents a loss of wealth at both ends
uh and uh the long-term effect would be
to transform much of Europe into one
large Meto or East Germany for decades
that's an opinion shared by two eoms as
different as VAV clous and Paul Krugman
that doesn't mean to say it's the
correct view uh of course but it
establishes the fact that it is not an
eccentric or marginal
View the second ism is the Pol Sol the
policy is an expression of
institutionalized historicism admirers
of called POA here will recall his
criticism was that historicism was an
impoverished Theory it replaces serious
debate about different policy choices
with a defeatist accommodation to some
supposed inevitability but as kan's
remarked and this is one occasion where
I think you'll agree with kain's um the
unexpected did always happens the
inevitable
never in this case the policy rep
reflects the determination never to
retreat from a previous Advance towards
an ever closer Union of the European
Union promised in the treaties a myth of
inevitability is the very definition of
historicism and the statements of
European leaders on the Europe
repeatedly Endor that that mental uh
approach um I would have thought myself
that Europe had already suffered quite
enough from the politics of historical
inevitability in the last century but
I'm an Anglo-Saxon
empiricist what does that matter my
third criticism uh is that this policy
is incompatible with democracy and this
is where we
see we see this most clearly in Greece
the remedies embodied in the fiscal
Union essentially entail Promises by
governments of nation states to keep
their structural deficits within agreed
limits and to submit their budgets for
approval
before presenting them to National
parliaments when I first began to look
at this a few years ago um we I didn't
have the example of Greece so I invented
an exag imaginary I didn't invent the
imaginary Kingdom of Rania uh that was
in that's a long-standing idea but I
examined how Rania might find itself in
these circumstances um if the if a
ranian budget I thought was presented at
Brussels and passed with distinction not
much happened if the budget was
disallowed by Brussels however would the
parliament be able to proceed with it or
would R rainia feel it couldn't do so
and what if the budget reflected a wider
set of government economic priorities
that had just been endorsed by the
ranian voters in each of these examples
the EU has intervened perhaps decisively
in ranian domestic politics we can sum
it up as follows if the ranian budget
does not need to be approved by Brussels
then the fiscal Union rests on the same
shaky foundations as the 1997 stability
and growth pact that was quietly
abandoned with little or no protest from
Brussels in the early years of the
century before the EUR had even run into
crisis if it does not need the approval
of Brussels then Rania has ceased to be
governed democratically in fiscal
matters which are 95% of politics that
is not altered in the slightest by the
fact that ruritania might be represented
on the Brussels decision-making
committee
nor can it be seriously argued that
ruritania would be sharing in pool
sovereignty or shared sovereignty with
this European Partners shared
sovereignty creates a new Sovereign
power namely the EU and deprives the
previous Sovereign power in this case
Rania of its Authority all assurances to
the contrary are bogus and um and
perhaps I could put it
metaphorically a bachelor is a sovereign
power a married man enjoys the benefits
of shed
sovereignty now when we turn to
Greece we find everything that I
predicted about ruritania actually
happening in practice in earlier years
uh all the Greek political parties
except the then tiny and marginal
trotskyist uh party sitaa signed on to a
memorandum of understanding with the
northern European troa that imposed
heavy spending cuts on the country these
were necessary because Greece couldn't
pay its bills couldn't pay its bills
because it couldn't devalue uh because
it was in the Euro because it couldn't
pay its bills uh nobody was going to
lend it money and it would need other
people to lend it money so effectively
they had to go to they went to the
European Union and to the IMF now during
this period as I say terit was a small
party uh there Then followed a crisis
and several elections in which the major
parties were all rejected by the Greeks
and S ritza broke through on a Manifesto
of of rejecting uh the cuts austerity
and the memor memorandum of
understanding they then held um a
referendum that endorsed their rejection
that vote strengthened cit's hand
politically now let's be clear it had
absolutely no other Democratic or moral
Authority countries cannot vote
themselves access to other people's
treasuries which is what citer wanted to
do um but
nonetheless they were encouraged to
think this might be possible as indeed
it has proved to be by the by the other
countries in the Euro because the other
countries wanted Greece to stay in so in
a way they were able to use the other
Count's desire not to have any threat to
the Euro uh which I don't think it was
by the way um to to you're telling me
I've got 15 minutes okay I'm going to
yeah okay now
um
I'll so so the so that being the case um
the the the government went through a
series of um of meet meetings uh in
which it needed large sums of money it
now by the way has B bed so much money
that it won't it cannot conceivably be
paid uh for another 130 years A and B it
can't uh it's at the moment they are not
meeting the targets that the IMF and the
EU have Set uh to to justify the bailout
um and we'll see how that turns
out now um the fifth criticism is that
this policy will in encourage the
political extremism that the European
Union was allegedly devised to overcome
governments in democracies cannot simply
impose unpopular policies on their
voters they are even less able to do so
when when the policies are imposed on
them from outside and when they attempt
to do so they sew Dragon's Teeth in the
form of extreme populist movements that
promis to reject what the Orthodox
Democrats have
accepted today uh Al zius the leader of
a party who was unknown is inspiring
leftist movements all over Europe and
dragging respectable Social Democratic
party towards a policy of Reckless
spending expropriation and I would say
the general Outlook drawn from the
playright um Dario foe um whose play
best play is best known players can't
pay won't pay and that is in a way the
attitude of the European left as a
result of the Greek crisis now
uh in the uh in the recent um three
months ago in the great debate over
whether to bail out Greece Cyprus and
the German Finance Minister um um shael
Shel rather were on opposite sides in
fact Shel had devised a very good um
temporary grexit option which would have
actually Rel created a much better
outlook for both Europe and for Greece
um he they would have left the uh Euro I
think not temp they it was said
temporarily I doubt if it would have
been temporary and they would have been
given upfront debt relief um the fact is
of course that's the only way that
Greece can return to anything like
stability because while it's still
climbing out of a an endless austerity
uh it's never going to to be able to
have the uh resources to pay back the
debts I me if you if you make it
impossible for someone to prosper then
you make it impossible to repay their
debts and in a sense that's what the
entire Greek people are in that
situation at the moment of course they
are paying back some of their debts but
the latest news as of yesterday was that
whereas they are supposed to have a um
amassed enough funds equal to
0.5% of their GDP uh this year the IMF
estimates that they are going to
actually they claim they've done that
the IMF claims that they have actually
done uh reach only half that figure and
I do not see how a country which is
facing an exchange rate uh which
effectively means that it will be
forever climbing up an incredibly
difficult financial and economic Hill I
don't see how he's going to be able to
to to assemble the resources and to save
enough to be able to get out of its
situation um as I say Shel devised a
Humane solution Greece would leave the
Euro receive generous debt relief to
stabilize grow its economy allowed the
drma to find a natural level and
re-enter the euro in due course I don't
believe that for this he was denounced
as a brutal Thug his proposal was
disavowed by Mrs Merkel and the bailout
that really is unworkable was then
approved over his not his objections but
of his reluctance the the
um another element in this which I think
you should pay attention to which which
ties into what was said by Christopher a
moment ago is that um the
uh let me find this
sorry um the left throughout Europe uh
suddenly thanks the left throughout
Europe suddenly decided that all of the
things that were supposed to be part of
the Europe deal namely if you can't pay
uh then uh if you can't run your economy
then the Europe's got to run it for you
it suddenly decided that this was
undemocratic and it wouldn't do it well
it is undemocratic but on the other hand
if you make yourself a detor your
creditors are going to have some
influence on your actions and the the
the situation in Europe at the moment is
on the one hand there is an attt to
pretend that is the case but almost
every time it reaches crisis point the
creditors give in and the the debtors
Live Another Day that doesn't help the
debtors because they're in an
unsustainable position and and it and in
fact one of the results of this is they
have to save they may not save enough
but when they do and then when they give
it to the other to the creditors the
creditors um then use it to buy
um um Industries and other things which
have been privatized well I'll leave it
at that point it's just to say that U
the some of those problems were
eminently foreseeable but no one
bothered to do anything to ensure that
didn't occur thank
you thank you John I was not lucky
enough 30 years ago to attend Hillsdale
where no student leaves without a great
introduction to Austrian economics but
providentially as a freshman at some not
to be named
College I was exposed to Austrian
economics at the foundation for economic
education and one terrific professor at
that time hoe Bacher who's here with us
Howe please wave I owe a lot to you
excellent
um introduced me to Austrian economics
and made me an enthusiastic Evangel
IST one of the things I did as I recall
was buy 200 copies of the law and beat
all my college friends over the head
with it for several
years at one point a couple years later
I went to Austria for the first time a
marvelous and beautiful country and was
shocked shocked that I couldn't find
anyone who had heard of the Austrian
School of
Economics or mises and Hayak I was so
crushed I knew I had a lot of work ahead
of me to introduce Austrian
economics um it's my pleasure to
introduce you to our next speaker Dr
Barbara col she is in fact president of
the Friedrich hyek Institute in Vienna
Austria whose mission is the Revival of
Austrian economics in that
country she's also director of the
Austrian economics Center she's an
associate professor of Austrian
economics at the University of Dona
gurria in Montenegro she whites writes
widely and I see see her turn up
speaking at many many Think Tank forums
and international Gatherings where
public intellectuals meet and discuss
economics uh she's a terrific manager of
of a worldwide Think Tank and a great
Economist please join me in welcoming
Barbara to talk about the common
currency and its
[Applause]
problems thank you Chris for this kind
introduction um I would also like to
thank uh Anita fsam for inviting me it's
a pleasure to be here at the place
obviously where austan economics is
valuated highly and we have had a couple
of interns in Vienna from Hillsdale
College and it was a pleasure to work
with them and I have to give credit to
you who educate them how well how well
educated they are so thank you for doing
this uh great job um my presentation
today of course was a little bit
hijacked by uh by John but it doesn't
matter at all because um being a
European I would it would be too
one-sided to only cover the the
so-called common currency which is a
huge problem I would like to uh present
the current situation as it is right now
the EU has led plans to strengthen the
monetary Union but actually those
official documents that we have just
seen are more than ambiguous at best if
we could say um France uh wants a
voluntarist economic government in
contrast to what Germany wants and you
have already mentioned what sh's vision
and sh's idea the Germans want to strict
to a rules based uh economic
Constitution so you see the differences
uh and the the contrast could not be
larger in addition to that uh we see
Cameron who wants a change of the
treaties uh before the British vote and
the referendum which by no means will
happen because Brussels and by Brussels
I mean the European politicians those
who are in power um they cannot dare to
take this risk because if a treaty
change should should happen then it's
definitely not in favor of the European
Union
people's uh ideas towards or the the
sentiment towards the EU has changed
largely in the past two years actually
it started already when the first
bailouts happened with Greece back then
uh everybody uh was fell into the Trap
and the into the political trap that
Angela Merkel has laid out as a
politician very wisely by tying the fate
of the European Union with the survival
of the uh of the Euro so I mean we all
know these are completely two different
things and you don't put them in one
basket merel as a politician wisely did
so and everybody fell into this trap and
until now everybody of those politicians
who are in power believe that and uh I
think this is this tragedy of this uh
that we see these days is also one
result um another thing that I would
like to emphasize is that both the
French and the Germans they both want
this federalized Europe the more
integration but with different ideas in
the background as I mentioned uh but the
treaty adaption is is not on the table
right now but um it
is without question that Germany would
have and this is very important would
have to change its constitution of
1949 if a treaty if the treaties are to
be changed and and we will you might you
will hear later as well uh the Europeans
actually Germany has already a tough and
serious problem with the Constitution
with their own Constitution that they
have broken uh when it comes to European
stability mechanism efsf and the other
bailouts so these are issues that we
have on the plate plus and this is the
most important thing and this is why the
sentiment towards the European Union has
changed so much in the past is that
Europe has definitely failed on three
fronts in the past decades the one is uh
the common currency that we the results
of that are being made visible with the
Greek crisis uh and ever since the
financial financial crisis the so-called
financial crisis hit Europe which is
nothing else for us than the V than
making the sovereign debt crisis visible
the sovereign debt crisis that roots
from those terrible welfare states that
uh Christopher has already discussed and
that we that we unfortunately are unable
to to kill so we have the monetary
crisis the debt crisis we have Ukraine
where we terribly failed as EUR as a
European union and as a consequence also
on the defense level and and on uh
securing our outer borders and and of
course helping Nations who are actually
more European than Russian or anything
else um and the third point is the
so-called migration crisis which is not
a migration crisis uh per se because
again here our politicians uh do a very
good job in throwing one uh to to
putting everything into one basket and
the one size fits all solution is also
true here those migrants are have three
different Roots one is the War uh PE the
people who flee from war those refugees
it's about onethird that come to Europe
the other third is people from Kosovo
ser Macedonia the Balkans that are
economic refugees if you want to call it
like that who seek a better future in
our welfare states but also and this is
most important are willing to work and
those guys have done that 30 years ago
uh and 40 years ago and they were just
our guest workers and those people
should just be welcome by all means and
allowed to work immediately and not put
in refugee camps and the third uh group
is uh the subs saharian Africans mostly
male uh 17 to 28 years old with a Muslim
background who are sent on a mission uh
also to seek uh a positive and good
future in
Europe um I'm time flies again so I just
simply uh also will fly over those
couple of slides that I have presented
but I would like to point out that this
peace project that was laid out uh after
World War II is actually now an entire
political project and by you cannot run
a continent only politically you have to
look at economics I mean these are the
principles we don't have growth in
Europe anymore I mean if we you cannot
call 0.8% in average growth I mean this
is ridiculous so these things are are at
are our real problems and uh finally let
me say I mean our politicians live or
seem to live in a parallel universe they
simply don't look at the facts and
figures they don't care for those having
this big political project in
mind
um I would like to also when let me
finally get into into the
presentation um we have to look at at
the reality with the Euro I mean we have
not only not all European member states
of those 27 member states use the euro
as a currency uh it's it's as a matter
of fact it's it's 2third I mean Finland
Great Britain Sweden um sorry uh Sweden
uh Great Britain Poland Czech Republic
Romania Hungary um are out of the Euro
they use their own currencies and only
uh a couple of countries have a have the
their currency pack to the euro uh which
is Denmark and bulgar Bulgaria and I
think this this is needs also to be
taken into
consideration um we have uh two really
two important and different views of
Europe that I already pointed out uh
this is the France and and and the
German uh issue or you could also say
the Socialist and the and the Republican
or the democ more democratic Christian
Democratic uh Vis uh vision of Europe
um uh and I would simply start uh with
what Milton fredman actually pointed out
uh and Milton Freedman was very critical
about the Euro and uh now we
unfortunately or we have to tell we have
to say yes right he was um those
flexible uh rates would work and uh if
if we allowed them without interference
and we have already heard before by the
other by the previous speakers uh
that because of this political
intervention that we see these days the
ECB the European Central Bank is not
independent anymore it was supposed to
be and I will come a little bit later to
the points that ising made uh but right
now this is not this is definitely not
the case I would uh say the polit the
shocks the economic shocks are able can
be absorbed in a single currency uh look
at the United States it has happened
plentyful and it worked out um
imbalances will are always there but uh
in Europe it is it it does not work
because of this one size fits all
policies and the ideas that we have to
do everything with the same Solutions we
know that uh what the US have tried in
the 30s did not work out and and
unfortunately we fall into exactly the
same trap doing the same thing
um this quote I think stands for itself
and there is nothing to add um however I
would like to bring in a very hakan idea
uh into into consideration uh competing
currencies that actually otma ising who
was one of the ECB board members and one
of the German national bank's heads uh
pointed out he he made a very ELO
eloquent uh defense of the Euro back
then and in 2000 and uh and tried to to
bring in the idea uh that um you have to
um to to unach um fi uh money and
finance policy however this was the the
original idea of the Euro but reality
shows that now it doesn't it doesn't uh
happen so those
expectations um did not work out and uh
Hayek's ideas with uh the competing
currencies uh unfortunately um are also
completely forget forgotten we we would
we would have to have a look that now we
are 15 years into this Euro um
experiment um and we still we still try
try to use the same Solutions and and
and follow follow in um and and and and
and the same solutions that have not
worked out um I would like to I would
like to focus on two more things that
are important uh this classical liberal
view that I already mentioned with which
was uh when when uh when we look back in
history and the European Union was
founded are the first steps towards the
coal and steel Union and and then
following up with the European common
market um the history in
5968 um when Maurice Schuman and alici
de gaspari and also um adwa and and uh
the Christian democrats had their
project for the values and their values
were individual liberty and freedom and
people who decide for themselves they
believed in the subsidiarity principle
they believed in not in the nation
states as we know it right now but they
believed that in Sovereign Nations who
govern themselves who are the owners of
their tax revenues who make their
decisions and if the B if the budgets
run out of balance then they are held
responsible for that whereas in contrast
to the French uh and socialist view
which is is actually the classic dor and
and and M uh program um where we aim for
a Central State this big Central Europe
that is governed out of Brussels by
technocrats and bureaucrats who are not
elected and this is this is a big
problem that that we face and we now run
into this um redistribution on the
supranational level which is actually
thanks to the socialist
ideas um a a huge disaster uh and by you
know under the disguise of protecting
the consumer um we run into regulation
after regulation which destroys uh
competition and uh productivity in
Europe and also the environmental uh the
the entrepreneurial environment um as a
matter of fact um 2third of the French
population are uh sorry of the labor
force are directly or indirectly um uh
are working for a government for the
French government either because they
are bureaucrats or teachers Etc or
because they run or they work in the big
state-owned companies do you think that
a nation like that is productive and and
those people uh earn and and and the the
taxes are used well in contrast to the
German
so so so-called middle stun where you
have uh a lot of small and medium-sized
companies uh that pay their taxes that
hire people and that are very uh
creative and Innovative and I think this
Innovation the lack of innovation that
we see these days in Europe is a huge
problem
um so we all know that this bailout of
of Europe has failed I would simply C up
uh come with a couple of figures and
numbers um why the about about uh about
Greek about Greece and then you and then
you will see uh that we actually cannot
afford this uh this stuff anymore just
to give you an idea uh the first bailout
was 110 billion uh followed by 130
billion uh only Greece then we had
Ireland with 85 billion we had Portugal
with 78 billion
and the first round was 430 which led to
this esm that I already mentioned right
now uh we are in the program of
qe3 uh with 1 Point um one trillion a
release of 60 billion euros
monthly uh starting this spring ending
next fall uh but we are already we
already know it this is not enough we
will have to take take more on on on
those balance sheets and um the qe4 is
already in discussion and the pr the
prolonging of of this uh bailout program
as well and our politicians are playing
a couple of tricks on our European um
citizens it's not only um that we do QE
we have the target 2 program um we have
um the new Yuna plan which is in in
addition to the European stability
mechanism nothing else but a huge
leverage system again um that will uh
that will help huge
distortions so what are the Alternatives
what are the solutions one could say
okay uh if the Greeks did not leave and
by the way I wrote an article in uh in
2010 predicting well Economist should
not predict and as an Austrian I should
not say anything since we all know there
is no such thing as full information um
but I by reason and having
underestimated the political desire to
stay in power by re by sheer reason one
would have had the Greeks make leave the
Euro back then already and let a couple
and this has to be stated and let a
couple of banks go bust and but this did
not happen just because we needed to
save the European the Euro and the
European Union so I me mentioned one
point at the beginning and this is
something where one has to give credit
but in the wrong way um we need NATO
Greece is a NATO position back the
furthest and Southeast and actually we
need that and given what is happening
further in the East it's even more
important but I tell you why Greece is a
failed nation and it's now under
protectorate of Brussels Greece remain
Still Remains um the largest defense
spending country within the NATO at the
28 members in relation to its GDP it has
500 misarranged or misarranged military
bases and 17 training camps so you know
those things don't work but money is
still put there and the German taxpayer
is actually paying for that uh our other
nations Great Britain um I mentioned the
referendum irand is fragile uh but
better now they left the umbrella uh
Portugal is still in Dire Straits and
with the current elections the com next
elections coming we might face another
Socialist Communist government I would
not be so mildly uh as what you said
about tias they are communists and you
know by that you just uh destroy an
entire
continent Germany is leading uh is still
still the leading economy apart from
some diesel problems uh but um I'm sure
they will overcome that or at least um
at least their lawyers and their
technicians Italy is no more Chita but
uh they have u a a wheat belt a bacon
belt from Venice to Milan to Torino
which is still working and they are the
small and mediumsized
Enterprises uh work hard gather revenues
and um are
flexible um one more thing we need
structural reforms without structural
reforms Europe is doomed and the same
thing what the Social Democrat sha did
in um when he was Chancellor um this
needs to be done entire for entire
Europe we need to um to do the our
structural reforms in pension in
taxes School uh and social welfare so
those four big things need to be uh
touched and then there might be a
solution for a year for a Europe or for
a Euro uh but I doubt it that we will
see this in the next two three years
thank
you
thank you very much obviously we have a
very learned and experienced panel on
the crisis various crises in Europe now
we do have just under 20 minutes for
some questions we do have microphones
around the room so please hold up your
hand and wait for a microphone we'll
start on this side of the room thank
you
I'm Joe pra the way some of these Europe
I don't know about all of them but the
ones that I'm familiar with which is
most they uh not
only Don't
Force undes relatively undesirable
immigrants to become part of their
culture they Pander to their differences
we've been in France probably 50 times
nowadays you're afraid to go to France
because they are there are all these
what is it 400 or so zones where normal
people can't travel because they are
occupied by some mosque and its
surrounding gang in Holland
uh in South Africa when the Dutch
controlled that and the French wanted to
send immigrants they had rules you can
stay here if you learn Dutch within two
years that was in the 1700s that was a
very good idea and now um in Holland
itself are they doing things to cause
the the Turks and the whoever is coming
uh to learn to assimilate into the Dutch
culture no thank you I think this
touches on one of the great angst in
Europe right now which is the threats to
if I can say it Christian culture
Christopher I think you've written quite
a bit on this would you care to respond
yeah I have this is uh it's tough to
know which way to go on this and I think
that's why Europe has failed so much
when you talk about the noo zones in
France and as they call them them
Zone I don't think it's the I don't
think it's that any particular mosque
has sort of like laid down the law and
says this is our area but there are are
what's what's going on is something very
much like uh what happened in um the
United States in the late 1970s where
for whatever reason the country feels it
has lost the legitimacy to enforce the
law um uh it it feels it has been unfair
um to poor people to ethnic minorities
to to to whatever and um there is less
enforcement in those places it might
also be I think you also hear people um
who live in those areas claim that it's
actually neglect that the government
doesn't care about those people enough
to to sort of enforce the the the law in
there in general though we have a
situation in France where
um it does resemble our crime in the
late '70s I I'll also touch on the
expectation
of cultural
assimilation it's very controversial in
Europe um because if you teach and this
is coming up now if you teach the Syrian
German um who were coming to to Germany
why would you teach them German you
teach them German if you expect them to
stay if you let them keep speaking
Arabic you can present this migration to
the public as being a temporary thing so
there are there are some
very there are some perverse political
incentives that do keep people from from
immigrating I I guess it comes down to
Europe's lack of a Melting Pot type
culture of the sort that we
have Bill Penn B Haven
University and uh I'll address this to
Mr Caldwell although it affects each one
of you each one of our speakers to what
extent do you think the decline in
Christian values in the home has caused
a lot of these problems and I think of
the whole area of personal
responsibility to the family um honoring
your word looking at the long-term
implications of your
decisions and again when I think of
Pensions to what extent do you have a
responsibility to your children and your
children to your parents and we could go
on and on but we see this decline in our
country as well and of course it has
been occurring in Europe for a lot
longer per period so I wonder if you'd
comment on that thank you as you say sir
we could go on and on this is a this is
a subject for a a large conference and
this panel is about um um the panel is
about economics and and you know it
would take a day to go over things like
keeping your word and things like that
but if we could just look at one area of
direct overlap with with economics which
is uh uh the family as a generator of
population as the generator of the Next
Generation right um then you can say
that you know again it's a complicated
matter how Christianity feeds into that
but the fact that Europe is no longer
made up of two parent families having
four or five children
is the reason this has happened I so I I
mean um let's so let's let's just try
and get to that that at Brass tax um
Europe is going through these problems
because it is not replacing its culture
and there's a lot of infrastructure that
needs to be kept running so it needs to
import a culture to run that that
infrastructure um that's probably the
simplest way to address it I know there
was interest on our other two panelists
for a quick response John yes there's a
if you read chesterton's biography
there's a story in it in which he tells
of how his father came home to dinner
one evening the chesteron were were and
are by the way a big real estate company
in in England in London um his father
came home to dinner one evening and was
in a very bad mood and he said well he
was terribly shocked because um someone
who was selling a house in which he was
the purchaser had the agent had proposed
to him that they agree on a higher price
than a market price and split the
difference between them with um with um
with fees and he said he he for the
first time in his career which was then
Advanced and uh this was the first time
anybody had ever made such a suggestion
to him now when we compare that with the
Moral Stories That emerged or immoral
stories during the Wall Street Crash of
how people and Wall Street were actually
conspiring with each other to defraud
many of their uh clients it it what
we're seeing here is you cannot have a
sound commercial morality it seems to me
unless you have a sound General Social
morality and that is one of the many
things that have gone and in in
searching for some comfort here and
there isn't much I would say uh we must
realize that we have in Europe certainly
and in this country too uh Christians
have allies in the post Christians the
people who while they no longer believe
in God uh or the the faith nonetheless
love the society which was created by
Christianity and I'm thinking of uh of
people like Douglas Murray in England uh
and others and who can be recruited to
support um both the the culture of
Christianity and some of the more
obviously relevant moral precepts
Barbara uh just quickly we have
substituted the churches with
bureaucratic institutions in Europe and
uh by that
uh we have also uh forgotten about our
Christian values toeo Christian values
uh which is you know also this living
within our means to be self-responsible
to be
competitive and uh also to achieve is
something that we have completely
delegated we've forgotten it and we have
delegated those values uh to a higher uh
reason to the state the government is
taking care of everything by now and we
no longer do it our solve our problems
ourself if you look at the budgets the
national budgets 23ds in average I mean
some are better luckily uh but my home
country Austria which has been quoted
and many others twoth thirds of the
national budgets are spent uh for social
welfare uh for programs for pension and
uh for paying those things and nothing
goes for the fut future so 2third of a
budget is just dedicated to the Past
what future for
Europe Dave Begley Omaha a question for
John or Barbara what's your outlook for
the near-term um for the private Greek
banking system thank
you sorry private private Greek banking
system oh I I'm I I wouldn't be
optimistic about it um but but um you
know in confusion there is
profit um not a very good one
overregulation overregulation
overregulation Brussels interfering in
anything uh in everything and
Independence of banks is is deeply uh
reduced uh we also have Basel 3 Basel 4
is already in in in process um our banks
still have not restructured restructured
themselves uh there are serious problems
that major Banks still have in in the
east in Russia and uh further uh and um
we have not done our homework and we are
not able and willing to let them go bust
which should
happen when when you look back in
history I got a question for the panel
when you look back in history there are
about 50 over 50 million overseas
Chinese
who immigrate from China and over 10
million Indian from India can you
compare and contrast the uh immigrants
problems with what we are facing right
now you're talking about about over
overseas Chinese and
Indians um I think they're
um uh it depends on which ones you're
talking about I mean there's a certain
um um entrepreneurial or or small small
business owning um uh Indian and over
Chinese population I think of the the
the the um the overseas Chinese in
Southeast Asia for instance or the
Indians as they existed in in East
Africa and then there is um uh the
labor of of the western United
States in the in the late 19th century
and the trajectories of those were um
were very different I mean I would say
that that there are tragedies in all
three of those immigrations that I've
described you have um you have the
expulsion of of the Chinese um in in
large degree from the United States you
have the massacre of Indians in in East
Africa under ID Amin you have um uh the
Indonesian sort of uh attacks on on on
Chinese
then you also have success stories and I
think those mostly concern the Chinese
entrepreneurs in Southeast Asia I would
say um that that this European
immigration is a mix of both the manual
labor type immigration and the
entrepreneurial immigration in which
manual labor predominates greatly I mean
as I said earlier sort of in in in an
economic sense probably the illegal
immigration is better for the economy
than the legal immigration Europeans
always talk about about how they need
you know um you know high-tech
scientists in the Germans have taken a
long time trying to create what they
call a green card program to get Indians
from India but in fact you know the the
Europeans need people to push
Wheelchairs and clean dishes too and so
um I I I would say so as I say I think
it's a mix of those experiences but with
a predominance W with with a domination
of the of the of the of the the manual
labor
type somewhere on this side where's the
microphone that back
uh Miss col for over two Millennium
there have been disagreements between uh
what we would not call Germany and and
what we now call France and the people
who've lived uh in those areas going
back to before Julius Caesar and in the
first half of the 20th century those
disagreements were inconvenient for
those of us who live in the US and
Canada um had to take care of certain
problems it's been great here for the
last several years that uh Team J
Germany and Team France have managed to
find a way to get along and so from from
one American's point of view looking
into the future for the currency to
break
up seems like it could lead toward
additional inconveniences are are are
you saying we should expect the currency
to break up between team Germany and
Team France and and does that mean the
free trade will break up will the will
the EU break up may I answer that
question I know I answered the last one
but I would I would like to address one
misconception that you hear from
Europeans all the time is you say what
is the point of this European project
and this Euro and they say 70 years of
peace they always say it the Defenders
of Euro the Euro always say it even
though the euro is 13 years old and it
was NATO that def defended the peace it
was NATO that that that that held up the
Cold War I think as long as there is a
Western Alliance of a NATO type I think
that is more I mean you can argue about
whether we need that or not but I do not
think that is the that it is the Euro or
the European Union that is the custodian
of Peace in Europe Barbara and then John
uh Europe has always been most
successful when political entities were
smaller than the econ than economic
entities and I would simply refer that
the future for Europe is we have two two
ways to go now we are definitely at
Crossroads if we don't solve this thir
crisis that I was referring to one is
more integration by all means one size f
fits all um going down the drain
definitely because we will lose uh
Global competitiveness and Europe will
remain what it is a beautiful maybe not
so nice place to live because we will
have social tensions and unrest uh but
it's but we will still remain a
beautiful country with a great history
and and and great traditions this is one
way I don't like that the better way and
here comes my free market and uh um
Freedom loving individual I would love
and I would like to see common borders
the Four Freedoms that are not in
practice yet and we keep Breaking All
the Rules I didn't cover that at the
talk but the Four Freedoms
working and competing regions a Europe
of competing regions where all the
diversity that we have that has added to
what we are to Our Roots that this can
flourish and that this can become a
Synergy for everything so whether we
have the Euro as a currency this is a
technical questions we have seen many
currencies come and go in Europe uh I
simply I'm
very yeah neutral about that but we need
to if we have a currency then this
currency needs to stick to the rules
that are made that have been made at the
beginning and we have broken the master
criteria and many many many other laws
and regulations that we have imposed on
us ourselves because we wanted to keep
this political project the European
Union uh alive but it doesn't have a
future if we continue like that so we
have to be more flexible have to look at
Alternatives and Mrs malel is famous for
her Tina talk there is no alternative
there are Alternatives one has to be
creative and the new I mean just the new
technology will bring so much uh
additional challenges and opportunities
that I'm positive that we will have to
look at our for at our borders the
common borders but the rest should be
very flexible Europe was more was more
Li liberal libertarian in in the in our
sense libertarian 100 years ago than it
is now back then could move from St
Petersburg to Lisbon without without a
passport and you could wire money you
could not wire back then but you could
transer uh transfer uh transport money
from Great Britain to uh Athens without
any problems that you didn't have to
have a license to be a German
hairdresser to operate in in Portugal
etc etc so we need to go back to this
competing markets system thank you we
have no more time for questions but I'll
give 30 seconds to John to close us out
um you mentioned that the disagreements
between France and Germany cause some
trouble for this part of the world it's
true it's also caused some trouble for
us too I I was born in a house in in
1942 which uh when my mother was
carrying me um was bombed by the LT wer
um the the um they were in the garden um
the Anderson shelter at the time in the
garden and after the bomb had landed and
gone through didn't explode it was an
incendiary bomb uh they went they went
back to bed uh and I asked my mother
very extraordinary thing to do and she
said well we were so exhausted during
the war you know so keep calm and carry
on you know that's the thing now just to
uh just to add to Christopher's Point um
what kept the peace in Europe from 45
onwards was the presence of the United
States as a European power with Force
because everybody knew the Americans
would not tolerate serious differences
between the different countries and they
certainly wouldn't tolerate them
developing into a violent struggle um
the Americans I hope will remain there
but the important thing is not to allow
the circumstances to be created or to
evolve in which everybody in which these
countries feel compelled to battle each
other the it seems to me it's not the
existence of free trade which is causing
en the present enormous set of conflicts
and annoyances disagreements between
countries resist to the EU it's the fact
that parts of the EU and parts are very
good parts are utopian projects thank
you John and that's and if you indulge
in utopian projects you will get people
resisting them and that's what we we
therefore need to move to the kind of
Europe that Barbara was describing
please join me in thanking our
panel